مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
الى تل ابيب ويؤكد العمل على تخفيف التوتر
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيه
مشروع
ضاحيه الفرسان والمرحله الثانيه من ضاحيه
خزف
شركه ارامكو تطلق ذراعها الرقميه مليار
و900 مليون ريال حجمه الاستثمارات
في الرابعه
رحله التطوير في العلا مستمره بدو التشغيل
لتجهيز اكثر من 12 الف واحده سكنيه
وفندقيه
[موسيقى]
صداره شباك التذاكر في السعوديه عوائد
تقدر باكثر من 20 مليون ريال
وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى اسرائيل
قادما من القاهره ولد وصوله للمطار
فيها ضروره التخفيف التوتر بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين مشيرا الى ان
هذا الامر مسؤوليه الطرفين
انه سيطرحوا خلال زيارته ضروره التوسل الى
حل الدولتين لانها صراع
يمكن هكذا في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره المصري
سامح شكري انه يعمل مع مصر على تخفيف
التوتر بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
واكدا على دوري مصر الجوهري في حال
القضايا الاقليميه كما هو الشان في ليبيا
والسودان وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري
اكد من جهته على انستقرار مصر يسهم في
تحقيق المصالح المصريه
الموضوعات التي نوقشت خلال مباحثتنا عكست
بجلاء التقارب الواسع في مصالحنا
الاستراتيجيه
واتساق الكبير في رؤيه في رؤانا تجاه
العديد من القضايا كما ظهرت ايضا وجود
امكانيات هائله لتطوير شركاتنا
الاستراتيجيه في عديد من المجالات مع
الوزير تشرف صباح اليوم وين استقبله فخامه
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي تم خلال اللقاء
استعراض اول العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين طبيعه الاستراتيجيه لهذه العلاقات
قدر التوافق القائم في ما بين رؤى البلدين
سواء في مجال تطوير العلاقات بين
الاستراتيجيه فيما بيننا او فيما يتعلق
بتناول القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبيه زياد
مرحبا بك زياد يعني بعد زيارته للقاهره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه لتل ابيب في
زياره التوقيت يتصاعد فيه التوتر ايضا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
هل نتحدث عن مقترحات عمليه مسار جديد ام
تسجيل الحضور
حات عينيه يحملها بلنكن هي الزياره الاولى
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي لاسرائيل بعد
تشكيل الحكومه اليمنيه الجديده برئاسه
نتنياهو يعني باستثناء
تقريبا كل الاداره الامريكيه وصلت
سلوفان ومن ثم رئيس ايضا بيرنس موجود في
اسرائيل والان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
هناك ثلاثه امور تقلق الامريكيين وسيع
ويحاول معالجتها في حواره مع اركان حكومه
بدءا بالاخير الامر الاول هو ضروره عدم
همم فقدان السيطره عما يحدث على الارض
بالنسبه للموضوع الفلسطيني
يريدها وزراء متطرفون في حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو الامر همم يعني بما بما بمعنى اخر
سيضع يده مجددا في اللعبه القديمه ذاتها
اداره الصراع بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين ليس اكثر من ذلك همم
الامريكيون يعني يحذرون اسرائيل بانه في
حال ايضا جرى الانقلاب على نظام القضاء في
اسرائيل وهي خاشيه امريكيه همم ستجد
واشنطن صعوبه في الدفاع عن اسرائيل في
المحافل الدوليه الامر الاخر اذا ارادت
اسرائيل التقدم في اتفاقات السلام
والتطبيع مع الدول العربيه عليها الا تكسر
قواعد اللعبه في الموضوع الفلسطينيه
والموضوع الاخير والاهم طبعا وموضوع ايران
بالنسبه
لجانبين همم سيطلب عدم مفاجاه واشنطن همم
من قبل اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بضربه للمنشات
النوويه الايرانيه ووجوب باست التنسيق
والعمل المشترك في مواجهه المشروع النووي
الايراني كيف سيتعامل النابلينكن ضمن هذا
اليطار
يعني هناك بعض المراقبين الذين يقولون
مثلا بان همم الاداره الامريكيه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي لا يملك القدره على
ممارسه اي ضغط او اي صيغه للتعاملات مع
حكومه نتنياه لوضع مسار للعمليه وبالتالي
فسيكون الدوري الاكبر من هذه الناحيه على
مصر تقريبا خاصه بعد الزياره الاخيره
هذا صحيح هناك صعوبه جمه في التعامل مع
هذه الحكومه واساسا ثم ترس من التوتر في
العلاقه التي تربط نتنياهو باداره بيدن
والاداره الديمقراطيه هذا سر معروف ومكشوف
وبالتالي لم يتغير بهذا المعنى هناك شك
متبادل بين الاداره الامريكيه وحكومه
اليمين الاسرائيليه الجديده ايضا عمليه
بطبيعه الحال سيحاولون العمل معها ولكن
بدون تشك يدرك بلينكن همم بان مساله مثلا
تقدم في الموضوع الفلسطيني تكاد تكون
معدومه نقصد بذلك الموضوع السياسي المسار
السياسي لا يبدو انه مطروح وليس في الافق
اصلا همم ما تبقى هو منع الي انهيار
الكامل بمعنى انهيار السلطه في رام الله
وانهيار الوضع الفلسطيني بشكل كامل
كمواجهه شامله في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
انتفاضه او حرب على قطاع غزه وما الى ذلك
وبالتالي
يعني محاوله دعنا نقول اطفاء حريق اكثر من
محاوله معالجه جديه
الفلسطيني يعني في ما عنا طبعا موضوع
القدس مثلا في موضوع المستوطنات في موضوع
القرارات الاخيره التي يقرها بنيامين
نتنياهو عن المستوطنين كذلك في موضوع
التنسيق الامن بين الجانبين الفلسطينيين
ما الذي يمكن ان يتحرك فيها
يعني ستكون نتائج متواضعه في كل الاحوال
بمعنى اساسا
والاداره الامريكيه لا تاثير يذكر لها على
موضوع العمليات الفرديه التي تجري هذا ولا
اي دوله في المنطقه ايضا هذه هذا امر خارج
السيطره ان استمر همم ولكن المفاتيح لوقف
هذا الموضوع هو ربما الضغط اكثر على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم يعني تخفيض سقف
العمل ده خلال الدفه الغربيه المحتله وفي
القدس عمليا يعني راينا الان مثلا حمله
هدم بيوت كبيره بضغط من الوزير همم بن
كزير تتم الان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
يستطيع ان يضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فيما يتصل بالتنسيق الامني بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل عمليه ان هذا همم سبق وتخذ
القرار مرتين وبعدها تجدد التنسيق في
المرحله همم وبالتالي هذا قد يكون متروك
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله عمليا بطبيعه
الحال شكرا جزيلا لك من القدس مراسله
العربيه زياد حلبي
تحدثت مصادر طبيه الباكستانيه عن مقتل ما
لا يقل عن 32 شخصا واصابه 147 اخرين في
انفجار انفجار احد المساجد بيشاور في شمال
غرب باكستان وفق السلطات المحلي ونقلت
وكاله رويترز عن مصدر طبيا باكستاني قوله
ان معظم القتل في انفجار مسجد بشاور من
رجال الشرطه مراسل العربيات
ناتج عن عمليه
سابقا سحابها من هدنه مع سلطه اسلام اباد
اعلنت شركه الوطنيه للاسكان في السعوديه
عن اكبر ضاحيه سكنيه جديده في مدينه
الرياض وهي ضاحيه الفرسان والمرحله
الثانيه من ضاحيه خزانه لتصبح اكبر معروض
عقاري في العاصمه الرياض وستوفر الثمانين
الف وحده سكنيه وتاتي ضحيه الفرسان على
مساحته 35 مليون متر مربع في شمال شرق
الرياض تستهدف بناء اكثر من 50,000 واحده
سكنيه في منطقه المرحله الثانيه من ضاحيه
خزام في شمال العاصمه الرياض على مساحه
تتجاوزوا واحدا 20 مليون متر مربع وتستهدف
بناء
30,000 وحده سكنيه
استديوهاتنا رئيس تنفيذي للشركه السعوديه
للاسكان محمد البوطي حياك الله استاذ محمد
خزام وضاحيه فرصه مش اهم التفاصيل المحيطه
بهذين
الحمد لله نعلين عن مشروعنا واكثر مشاهده
في الرياض ولا يفوتنا حقيقه في هذا المقام
لان نتقدم بشكل جليل لسمو سيدي ولي العهد
على الدعم الكبير والمستمر
لمنظومه الاسكان بشكل كبير نحو التحقيق
مستندفات رؤيه 2030 همم واللي الحمد لله
الدائمه الكبير وصلنا الى النسبه او تجاوز
ال 60% في 2020 وان شاء الله الى تحقيق
النسبه المستهدفه في العشرين 30
طبعا
بالنسبه لمدينه الرياض وزي ما ذكر معالي
وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه والاسكان
الاسبوع الماضي في منتدى مستقبل عقار تحدث
عن المعروضه العقاري في مدينه الرياض اقل
من البطن بالضبط وذكر انه معه الوزير
الدعم الكبير والتمكين من الدوله ومن
الحكومه يد الله بتخصيص اراضي همم حقيقه
كبيره لضخ معروضه كبيره اليوم احنا في
الوطنيه الاسكان في الشركه الوطنيه
للاسكان يعني نطلق او نعلن اليوم عن
مشروعين همم في مدينه الرياض فيها معروض
عقاري كبير همم يتجاوز 80,000 وحده سكنيه
ستساهم في في في
توازن همم
كثير من الاسعار وايضا ستخدم شريحه كبيره
همم من من المستفيدين طبعا احنا اليوم في
في هذه المشروعين نخدم جميع الشرائح همم
في في في مشاريع راح تكون نوعيه متكامله
الخدمات
وان شاء الله راح تطلب
كبير في مدينه الرياض ممتاز ايضا الوزير
يمكن في اللقاء الاخير اتكلم بالاضافه لما
ذكرت عن المعرض والطلب عن مشكله ارتفاع
الاسعار ما زالت يجيء المستمره يمكن
اكثر من قدره الناس والمواطنين على التملك
يعني بالنسبه للاسعار الحريف بالتالي هذا
دائما المشروعين كيف راح يتم التاثير
عليهم ووو والمتوسط الاسعار فيها كيف
هيكون طب يعني احنا لما نصمم المشاريع
ونعمل على هذا المشرق يكون عندنا دراسه
للشريحه المستهدفه
بالذات شريحه المستحيل الدعم السكني
والمسكن الاول ولدينا دراسه من واقع من
واقع البيانات الموجوده يتم تصميم
المنتجات بما يوافق القدرات الشرائيه
المستفيدين حيث يكون عندنا يعني نلبي طلب
لكل الشرائح حسب البيانات من المستفيدين
المستحقين للدعم السكنيه همم اليوم
بحياتكم بحجم المشروعين همم
المشروع اولا لانه اسعاره ديت سكينه تكون
همم ذات جوده عاليه وباسعار مناسبه وافق
رغبات المستفيدين وايضا لانه في الجانب
همم اللي جوده الحياه والمرافق همم في هذه
المجتمعات اليوم مثل هذا المشروعين همم
النسبه التخطيطيه فيها والمسطحات الخضراء
مدروسه همم بالعكس يمكنها يعني في في
صمامات تكون توافق معي جوده الحياه عندنا
في مشروعنا في شمال الرياض او في
المشروعين اجمالي الحدائق مساعد حدائق
يتجاوز سته ملايمات المربع همم
في في مشروعنا في شمال الرياض في همم واحد
من اكبر حدائق مدينه الرياض حديقه العالم
سته كيلومترات وسبع كيلومترات همم كل هذا
انا اخذها في الاعتبار وايضا ان ما تؤثر
على اسعار وحدات سكينه بحيث انه يكون
الحقيقه متكامل الخدمات وايضا همم متميز
همم يقلل من اهم الخدمات اللي راح تكون
فيه
احنا في المشروع هذه نحن في الحقيقه تبنا
مدن
المشروع الواحد يعادل تقريبا ثمانيه الى
تسعه احياء من احياء مدينه الرياض فكل
الخدمات سواء مجمعات تجاريه من اسواق من
مدارس وخلافه تكون في في هذه الاحياء بحيث
انه تقلل الحركه حركه ساكنين
بشكل كبير خارج هذا الاحياء او هذا
المجتمعات ما عدا طبعا انتقال اذا كان
هناك عمل خارج همم
الحيه او المشروع همم حركه المشاهده
مدروسه بشكل كبير بحيث انه ممكن التنقل
داخل الحي بشكل كبير يعني ما يكون استخدام
همم سياره للمرافق القريبه او حتى المدارس
كل هذه تاخذ في الاعتبار في تصميم هذا
الاحياء همم بحيث انه ما تكون فقط تفكيره
في تقديم فقط وحدات سكنيه همم واسعار من
ايضا حتى جوده حياه
اقل من السوق يعني
لا تقل اسعار وحدات عن 20 ل 25% اقل من
اسعار المحيطه واحيانا تتجاوز ذلك في
الغالب يعني تكون هذه الاشعار السهدفه في
الغالب تكون اقل بكثير من الاشياء يعني
عندي متراح يبدا العمل على المشروع همم
متى متوقع ان ينجز ان يتم على ارض الواقع
هنتكلم عن المشروع البيع على الخالق
كمان يعني هذين المشروعين همم كيف هيكونوا
شكلهم يعني بعد بعد التنفيذ ومتى وكيف
هتكون طريقه التقديم عليه جميل همم طبعا
احنا نعمل احنا في في عجل مستمر يعني
اليوم في الشركه الوطنيه الاسكان اذا
تكلمنا عن مدينه الرياض اا احنا اطلاقنا
مشاريع سابقه همم والجميله ان عندنا
مشاريع في شمال الرياض في شرق ايضا عندنا
في جنوب الرياض همم مجموعه كبيره من
المشاريع عليها همم هذه المشروعين قد هم
الاكبر حتى على مستوى المملكه لو قد يكون
حتى على مستوى المنطقه بالحجم الاماراتي
يتجاوز يمكن 60 ملي ريال وهي مشاريع يعني
كبيره جدا ايضا نعمل على ان تكون هناك
رحله امين سهله
وسلسه للمستفيدين من حيث همم التقديم او
الطلب همم وربط المستفيدين مع المطورين
احنا نعمل بشكل كبير همم مع المطورين
الاخرين في تقديم هذا الوحدات السكنيه
وايضا المستفيدين يتقدمون عن طريق همم
منصه سكنيه وتطبيق سكني بالامكان طلع على
كل المشاريع والحجز بطريقه سهله الى
التمويل الكتروني عن طريق البنك ممكن يكون
عن طريق التطبيق او زيارات مركز سكن
الشامل او زياره مركز المطور بطريقه سهله
تسهل على المستفيدين همم الرابط مع الجهات
التمويل وايضا معرفه الاسعار والتصاميم
والتقديم على الطلب والشراء طبعا همم في
الغالب احنا نكون همم من تاريخ الى الى
التسليم المتوسط 36 شهر ثلاث سنوات الى
التسليم والعجله مستمر
المشروعين بالضبط
في الرياض طبعا المشروع الاول جمعيه
الوحدات السكنيه
المرحله الثانيه احنا بدانا المرحله
الاولى تقريبا على مساحه عشر ملايين متر
بيعت بالكامل الحمد لله
بدانا سلم فيها بدء التسليم فيها وزي ما
قلت لك خزانه احنا اطلق لنا اليوم المرحله
الثانيه مرحله واطلقت وبعت بالكامل بل انه
بدا التسليم في بعض مراحلها
اسعارها تبدا شقق طبعا تبدا تقريبا من
350,000 ريال واحنا نطلع الى البلال
متوسطه هاي يمكن حدود
850,000 ريال هذا كان متواصل هذا
المتوسط
همم
المطورين زي ما قلت لك نخدم اكبر شريحه
ممكن انا موجوده
على شريحه يعني واحده فاليوم راح تحصل
عندنا شرائح كثير جدا ولكن نركز على
الشريحه الاكبر اللي هي تقريبا بين تقريبا
حدود 350 4 في حدود 9000 هذه نركز عليها
ولكن كل الشرائح الثانيه موجوده وناخدما
بالاضافه هذا شيء مهم لانه المرافق او
الخدمات التجاريه وخلافه ايضا ماخوذه في
الاعتبار وبحيث ان يكون الحي مكتمل
الخدمات مكتمل المرافق همم يعني مراعي ما
هي جوده حياته هذه يمكن مهمه جدا طيب
تساعد الساكنين انه يكون في حي متكامل
اقل سعر اللي انت تقول لي 3500 هذا
المتوسط
الاقل
خالد طبعا حسب المراحل بدايه المشروع تكون
الاسعار اقل وما يتقدم المشروع تكون
ما لها يعني ضابط محدد انا اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المعلومات رئيس تنفيذي
للشركه السعوديه شكرا
بعد قليل
مسرحيه غنائي ضخم في الرياض بالتزامن مع
يوم التاسيس بعد 22 يوم
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب على مدار 24 ساعه
بمستشفيات المواساه
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
عزله الدبلوماسيه عالميه وعدم الاعتراف
بها دوليا
[موسيقى]
طيب الديمقراطيه الرقميه الجمعه الواحده
بعد منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
ويتم توزي
ع
هذه الحرب ستقول وتتمدد وتتوسع
هنا مدينه لفيف التي تحتضن العدد الاكبر
من اللاجئين اي تدخل لحن شمال اسس في معنى
ذلك ان الحرب شامله
ان يكون هناك اعتراف بشبه جزيره العرب
[موسيقى]
سيكون حول وقت اطلاق النار بمقابل نحن هنا
وسط نهر الثامنه الذي يقطع الاراضي
الرومانيه عن الاوكرانيه منها الموقف
العسكري هو الذي يحدد الى اين تذهب
المفاوضات
التاليه بالساعه الماضيه تقول ماذا
بالنهايه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت اليوم شركه ارامكو
السعوديه عن انطلاق شركه ارامكو الديجيت
عزيزي ما كانت ارامكو في قطاع الطاقه بحسب
رئيس الشركه امين النصر النصر ذكران
ارامكو تخططوا الاستثمار يبلغ مليار
والتسع مئه مليون دولار خلال السنوات
الثلاث القادمه في المجال الرقمي واصفا
ذلك بانه اكبر استثمارا لشركه في هذا
المجال حتى ناصر شرائط ايضا الى ان
الاقتصاد السعودي من اسرع الاقتصادات نموا
في العالم ومن المتوقع ان تتجاوز قيمته
التريليون دولار لاول مره
نظران ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العسيمي عبد الرحمن مرحبا بك حدثنا
اكثر عن هذا المشروع شركه
ارامكو ديجيت
م من برنامج ومعرض اكتفاء الذي ياتي هذا
العام بنسخته السابعه هذا البرنامج الذي
يهتم بالتاكيد على اهميه الشركات المورده
والنتيجه القيمه المضافه لشركه ارامكو من
خلال هذا اليوم من خلال افتتاح الرسمي
لهذا المعرض وهذا البرنامج تم الاعلان عن
اكثر من 100 اتفاقيه بقيمه 27 مليار ريال
سعودي اي حوالي سبعه فاصله اثنين مليار
دولار سابع زميلي نصر ياخذ لكم جوله في
هذا المعرض نحن في جزء او في احد اجزاء
المعرض كما نشاهد خالد هناك عدد كبير من
مكاتب الجهات الحكوميه صندوق قيمه الموارد
البشريه وزاره الاستثمار وزاره التجاره
هيئه الضريبه والجمارك والدخل وعدد كبير
من القطاعات الحكوميه هذه القطاعات هي
قطاعات ممكنه لمبادرات ارامكو همم من خلال
تقديم الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بينها وبين
شركه ارامكو اليوم كان هناك
اهتمام كبير بتوقيع
الارامكو للشركه ارامكو الرقميه الجديده
وهي شركه اي دي سي شركه ارامكو الرقميه
وهي شركه تابعه وملوكه بالكامل لشركه
ارامكو هذه شركه خالد ستقوم بدور تسريع
تحول الرقمي في المملكه ومنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وايضا شمال افريقيا همم نائب
التنفيذي رئيس شركه ارامكو همم قال
للعربيه اليوم بان هذه
المبادرات تمثل منظومه للموردين المحليين
لشركه ارامكو وهي تعتبر اولويه قصوى لشركه
ارامكو ايضا نشاهد هنا على هذه الشاشه هذه
المعاهد خالد التي من خلال النسخ السابقه
الست لهذا البرنامج تم انشاء اكثر من 16
معهد لتدريب وتخريج المهندسين والمختصين
لشركات ارامكو التابعه لها في اكثر من عشر
مدن اا تم افتتاح 12 اكاديميه همم وايضا
خرجت اكثر من 48,000 شاب وشابه يبلغ عدد
السيدات السعوديات المتخرجات من هذه
المعاهد تقريبا خمسه الاف سيده خلال سنوات
قليله يعني شركه ارامكو كما نعرف هي من
اكبر واضخم الشركات في العالم وفي هناك
شركات كبيره بينه وبين عدد كبير من
القطاعات الحكوميه اليوم تم توقيع اتفاقيه
مع شركه زوم شركه استراتيجيه خالد تم
توقيع مع شركه دي اتش ال همم
لابرام اتفاقيه نهائيا لتنفيذ مشروع مشترك
ايضا اتفاقيه مع وزاره الاستثمار السعوديه
مع شركه حصان الاستماريه مع شركه
لتوطين وتطوير خدمات الت البيئي
والاجتماعي والحوكمه متوقع خلال
الايام القليله المعرضين يعني يمتد يا
خالد الى الثاني من فبراير فمتوقع خلال
الايام المقبله ايضا يتم نعم مضخم جدا
وكبير جدا خالد ومتوقع ان يشهد ايضا توقيع
عدد كبير من الاتفاقيات بين ارامكو وشركات
اخرى او بين الشركات فيما بينها النصر
ايضا الجميله شكرا جزيلا لك انت ايضا عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مراسل العربيه من الظهر
الى شمال غرب السعوديه حيث اطلق شركه
العلا للتطوير عمليات التشغيليه للدعم
وتطوير محافظه العلا من خلال التطوير
العقاري واداره الاصول شركه ستعمل على
التوفير فرص عمل وفرص ايضا للشركات
والمجتمعات في المحليه مع الحفاظ على واحد
من اكبر واقدم المواقع الثقافيه في العالم
كما ستسهم في تحويل المدينه التاريخيه الى
وجهه سياحيه عالميه
العنود العبدلي تعرفون اكثر على التفاصيل
الخطط التشغيليه لمشاريع التطوير العلا
كبير وفي اخر خطوات التطوير اطلق شركه
العلا للتطوير عملياتها التشغيليه لدعم
وتطوير المحافظه عمليات التشغيل ستتم من
خلال التطوير العقاري واداره الاصول وفق
استراتيجيه استثماريه طويله المدى حيث
ستوفر الشركه فرص عمل فرصا لشركات
والمجتماعات المحليه مع الحفاظ على واحد
من اكبر واقدم المواقع الثقافيه في العالم
وتشمل المشاريع المخطط لها اكثر من سبعه
الاف و500 وحده الفندقيه لتحويل المدينه
التاريخيه الى وجهه سياحيه عالميه اضافه
الى خمسه الاف وحده سكنيه وتجمع للموظفين
يضم اكثر من 1,000 وحده
صناعيه وبنيه تحتيه مسانده هذا الحراكم
مشاهدينا يعيدونا لشهر ابريل من العام 20
و21 حيث اطلق ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان الرؤيه تصميميه لمخطط رحله
عبر الزمن الذي يعد جزءا من برنامج تطويري
شامل للعلا تشرف تشرف عليه هيئه الملكيه
للمحافظه وتهدف استراتيجيه التطوير عند
اكتمالها في عام 20 35 الى توفيره
38,000 فرصه عمل جديده بالاضافه الى
المساهمه بمبلغ 220 مليار ريال في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للسعوديه
معلقاتنا امتداد امجاد عرضا مسرحيه غنائيه
يقدمه الامير عبد الرحمن بن مساعد
بنفعاليات يوم التاسيس السعودي في الثاني
والعشرين من شهر فبراير المقبل المسرحيه
التي تشرف على انتاجها هيئه المسرح
والفنون الادائيه تهدف الى ترسيخ الثقافه
السعوديه وكذلك دام جهود القطار الثقافي
المقرر يتم عرض هذه المسرحيه معلقات
الامتداد وامجاد في مسرح جامعه الاميره
نوره بنت عبد الرحمن
في المؤتمر الصحفي المصاحب للمسرحيه
الغنائيه معلقاتنا امتداد وامجاد كد
الامير عبد الرحمن بن مساعد ان هذا العمل
الفني يعد مرجعا تاريخيا للدوله السعوديه
في العمل هذا تحديدا اقدر اعتبر العمل هذا
كنص وكموضوع هو مرجع تاريخي لتاريخ
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدون جدال
مع تاكيد على حقيقه تاريخيه انه هل الارض
هي مهبط الوحي وهي موطن اللغه العربيه
وانها امتدادها الحضاري المهيب ل 16 قرن
هذا هذه الرساله الاساسيه لهذا العمل
جربي يذكر الامير احمد بن سلطان المشرف
على التلحين المسرحيه الغنائيه انا دوره
في المشاركه يقتصر فقط على تقديم الالحان
وتاليفها خلال العمل المقرر عرضه في يوم
التاسيس القادمه
ولذلك قلتها من قبل مراره ان تكرار انا
الشغف اللي عندي هو التاليف الموسيقي وليس
الاداء
سلطان الباز الرئيس التنفيذي نهايه المسرح
والفنون الادائيه الادائيه فقال خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي ان هذا العمل المسرحي تم
عرضه على ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وانه ذكر له انه من الاعمال المؤخره لان
تقدمها لسنوات
ايضا
العمل قال هل هذا من الاعمال اللي ممكن
تكون
كسوه طول العمر هذا مؤهل لكن
بمعنى العرض اللي يستمر للسنوات
وهذا في شروط حوله
تتوفر في المجتمعات في بروده في مكان بسبب
انه ال ال الصناعه المسرحيه متكامل
بتفرغ راشد الشمراني لمده سنه كامله للعمل
القسط انه يعني
وصولنا الى هذه المرحله طلب وجود كوادر
قادره تفرق نفسها للمسرح
ويكون اقتصاديات المسرح ايضا نمت عندنا
بالدرجه اللي تسمح بوجود عرض مستمر او
رزقه شو كمان
لكن هذا العمل تحديدا اعتقد المرشح بقوه
لان يعمل جوله في المملكه او خارجها
رابع ايضا مستمره في بعد قليل
فيلم ستار يواصل صداره شبكه شباك التذاكر
في السعوديه العوائد تقدر باكثر من 20
مليون ريال
الى تل ابيب ويؤكد العمل على تخفيف التوتر
بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين الف وحده سكنيه في الرياض
ضاحيه الفرسان والمرحله الثانيه من ضاحيه
خزام
شركه ارامك وتطليق ذراعها الرقميه مليار
و900 مليون ريال حجم الاستثمارات
ورحله التطوير في العلا مستمره بدو
التشغيل التجهيز اكثر من ثلاثه عشر الف
وحده سكنيه وفندقيه
[موسيقى]
العوائد حتى الان تقدم باكثر منها مليون
اهلا بكم من جديد قبل شهر تقريبا شهد
الدور السينما السعوديه تدشين الفيلم
الكوميدي ستار
حتى الان يتصدر شباك التذاكر في السينما
السعوديه الفيلم من بطوله ابراهيم الحجاج
عبد العزيز الشهري ابراهيم خير الله من
النجوم
حتى الان التي حققها الفيلم
في المسطار حديث الناس في السعوديه الفيلم
يواصل صداره شباك التذاكر طوال 30 يوما
حيث تم تسجيل العروض في التاسع والعشرين
من ديسمبر الماضي 20 22 عدد تذاكر المبيعه
في دور السينما مشاهدينا للفيلم الكوميدي
ستار تجاوز 450 الف تذكره بمعدل يتجاوز 13
الف تذكره يوميا ويجعله اكثر الافلام
السعوديه مشاهده في دور السينما تاريخيا
تراه الفيلم السعودي ولد ملكا الذي بلغت
مبيعاته 100 واحده 150 الف تذكره ثم فيلم
شمس المعارف ب 114,000 تذكره مبيعه
مشاهدينا ماذا عن العوائد التي حققها في
المخطار هل هي الاكبر في تاريخ السينما
السعوديه من خلال عدد التذاكر فان متوسطه
العوائد التقريبي يتجاوز 20 مليون ريال
خلال شهر واحد فقط
ذلك وفقا للرئيس التنفيذي لشركه افلام
شميسي المنتجه للفيلم ابراهيم الخير الله
عاد هنا الاوبن كابتشر ضروري يكون يفتح
النفس لانه مفتوح على الصاله
انضمالي هنا في الاستوديو الممثل والمنتج
السينمائي ابراهيم الخير الله ابراهيم
حياك الله اول شيء الله يحييكم
والف الف مبروك على نجاح الفيلم الارقام
اللي تاكد هذا النجاح اتكلم عن 20 مليون
ريال اااه ونتكلم عن اكثر من 450 الف تلك
تذكره احنا هذه ارقام التقديريه انتم اللي
عندكم الارقام الحقيقيه لكن انا ابغى اعرف
شلون وصلتوا لهذا الرقم
لما اعادت همم سينما السعوديه وافتتاح
الصلاه كان في عده افلام سعوديه موجوده
يمكن ثمانيه همم اقل وقت المغرب ويمكن صحح
لي
واغلبها يمكن كانت كوميديه وحاضيه التسويق
جيد لكن غلبه كمان
في الصلاه وفي العارضه اكثر ستار غير
المعادله تمام
الله بالخير جميعا من الرياض طلعه حلوه
بعد
ستار احنا لما بدانا فيه بدينا في التلفاز
اصلا كان عندنا زي ما انت عارف خط اوردي
ماشيين فيه افلام لي تلفاز فقررنا نفتح
ارم جديد في التلفاز والدراع جديده في
التلفاز متخصصه في افلام شباك التذاكر
واسميناها افلام الشميسي اهل الرياض
السنوات اللي فاتت في البدايه المتصدرين
الثلاثه افلام عربيه مصريه تعال خلينا
نشوف وش الخلطه اللي موجوده المصريين
الجمهور اللي موجود وانت ما تكتفي بس انك
تاخذ الجمهور ايش يعجبه لازم تضيف عليها
ايش بهاراتنا وكشنتنا وشغلاتنا وكبساتنا
وامورنا على اساس توصل لفيلم يشبه للي
بيقعد على الكرسي بيدفع فلوس عشان يقعد
على الكرسي فهمم من الدروس الافلام
المصريه
هو شغله هو اسطوري اصلا بنى عالم ثاني
يعني غير العالم لهذا ولكن سالتني عن
الصوص والخلطه هي ما يعجب ويكون قريب لكل
عائله لكل فرد لكل وحرصنا فيه يعجب
الجمهور السعودي شفتم انت تقول انا اخذت
او درست لحالك بالتالي وش النتيجه اللي
وصلت لها في الجمهور السعودي او الجمهور
السينما السعوديه يحبون الكوميدي يحبون
الاكشن فخلطنا بين الكوميدي والاكشن طبعا
في ستار كان فيه الكوميدي طاغي على الاكشن
بس الاكشن موجود واخترنا مظل اللي هي مظله
المصارعه لانها يعني قاعده تشتغل يعني
ممكن في العالم كله مو مره بس هنا شفنا
كراون جول مع الترفيه مثلا حضور خرافي
شفنا الناس لسه مهتمه بهذا الشيء واحنا
نذكر يعني لعبه المراكب في الصاله
وانتوا عملتوا خلطه عجيبه وخلطه دسمه فيها
الموضوع يعني
انت جبت كميه كوميدي جبتو كمان جريمه قتال
عوالم سفليه بس خليني اقول لك مثلا بعض
النقاد مثلا قالوا انتم عملتوا حاجه
واضفتوا فيها النكد السعوديه لكن الفكره
اصلا القالب قالب معروف حلو هذا اللي
موجود فيه هو اليود هذا الموجود فيه
بوليود مصارعه
صدق والله في شيء ثاني غير كده اللي
استفدت منا من الافلام العربيه هي
انت ما تمتعه بس بصريا امتع بعد سمعيا
عشان كذا في البوم نزل عليه
اصلا مؤشر لتسويق الفيلم طلع يعني احنا
اتابع من زمان يعني شفت من اجل زيكو مثلا
على سبيل المثال اللي رفع اكثر
انها عندها الغزاله رايقه كلنا نعرف
الغزاله ترى هذه اغنيه فيلم
وقص على ذلك في امريكا في نفس الشيء
المركز الخامس
الاكتشاف الجديد اللي عملته شادر الجفاري
كمان
لكن خليني اسالك عن الاضافه اللي قدمتها
اثناء ورش الكتاب انتوا مستعملتوا بايمن
والتوتر وايمن اسم معروف يعني مجال
التعليم في الكوميديا والصين من العمل ليش
استعنتوا فيه انا اقول لك ليش احنا اكثر
شيء سويناه شورت فيلم قبل هذا الفيلم
تحديدا انا يعني شخصيا في بروجكت هذا كامل
فانا ابغى اخاف يعني خوف كبير اني في ساعه
و45 لا يطيح الايقاع لا يطيح الايقاع لا
هذا اهم شيء فمن وين انا باجيب هذه
المعلومه غير ان واحد عارف طيب ما شاء
الله
ما يمل لازم الواحد في الشق الاول
في هذا الجزء الاول لازم ما تتعدى دقائق
معينه اللي انت معطيني شيء يعلقني في
الجزء الثاني هي تجزء الفيلم من قصه شاب
يعني الاول والثاني والثالث ما اطلع من
الاول الا معطيك شيء يعلقك تدخل في الثاني
يعطيك شيء تدخل في الثالث
الين اسلمك السلام عليكم هذا التتر
ابراهيم الترافات والسقف في السينما
السعوديه ويمكن انا رجعت لواحد من النقاد
والكتاب في السينما وقال ستائر خل السينما
السعوديه والفيلم السعودي قبل 16 شيء وبعد
16 شيكل ثاني اليوم مش تفكرون فيه يعني
بالنسبه للسينما في مشروعكم القادم او
المشروع الثاني ايه في الكلام احنا احنا
نفكر بس في مشروعنا الثاني الحاله احنا
نفكر بس في ال- المشاريع السعوديه كلها
لان صراحه لازم تدخل السينما السعوديه تبي
تشوف كم فايف لازم يكون في اقل شيء اثنين
ثلاثه
الفيلم السعودي لازم يكون اقوى من الفيلم
اللي جاي من خارج السعوديه
مع الحكومه الكويتيه قريبا لتحديد نقاط
الضعف اتفاقيه العمل المشتركه والاسباب
التي قد تكون في مقتل الخادمه الفلبينيه
جوليا نارا في الكويت
مره اخرى
اطلقت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه خدمه اصدار
تاشيره المرور للزياره للقدمين الجوال
الالكترونيه الوزاره ضافتنا القرار يدخل
حيز التنفيذ بدء من اليوم وذلك عبر التقدم
بطلب الزياره جو عبر من الصوت الناقلات
الجويه السعوديه قبل ان يتم تمريرها الى
المنصه الوطنيه الموحده للتاشيرات
لمعالجتها واصدار التاشيره بشكل فوري
مؤكده انها مجانيه وتمتد صلاحيتها لثلاثه
اشهر
واقامه اربعه ايام
كل هذه الايام سنشاهد كوكب الزهره بالعين
المجرده وقت الغروب خالد الزعان
[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الايام وان طالع من صلاه المغرب
اتجاه جهه الغرب ستشاهد جرم سماوي جميل
ولافت هذا الجرمسماوي يسمى بكوكب الزهره
والزهره ثالث المعجرم سماوي بعد الشمس
والقمر والعرب اسموه بالزهره لانه يزهو
بجماله والعامه يسمونه ابنتي العشاء لانه
يظهر في وقت العشاء ويسمى ايضا بالكوكب
الدري لانه كالدره بجماله وضيائه جاءت
معلمتي في غيرها بالغسق كانها الكوكب
الدري في الافق فقلت نورتني خير زائرتي
اما خشيتي من الحراس في الطرق فجاوبتني
ودمع العين يسبقها من يركب البحر لا يخشى
من الغرق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واهم الاجرام السماويه عند شعوب الارض
قاطبه الشمس القمر الزهره الشعره فشعوب
البدائيه عبدت الشمس وعبدت القمر والشعوب
التاليه لها عبدت الزهره والعرب عبدو
الشعره ومع مدير الاسلامي ابطل عليهم هذا
بقوله وانه هو رب شعره ومن الجميل اننا
خلال هذه الايام سنشاهد زحل والزهره
والمشتري والشعره بشكل لامع فوجدته تقبيل
السيوف لانها لمعت كبارها المتبسمين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرابعه نختماد العلوي
لكن يغادر القاهره الى تل ابيب ويؤكد
العمل على تخفيف التوتر بين اسرائيل
والفلسطيني
واحده سكنيه في الرياض ضاحيه الفرسان
والمرحله الثانيه من ضاحيه خزنه
شركه ارامكو تطلق ذراعها الرقميه مليار
و900 مليون ريال حجم الاستثمارات
ورحله التطوير في العلا مستمره بدو
التشغيل لتجهيز اكثر من
12.1 سكنيه وفندقيه
[موسيقى]
وفي المصدار واصل صداره شباك التذاكر في
السعوديه العوايد تقدر باكثر من 20 مليون
ريال
[موسيقى]